how much money is the soccer industry
worth quite a lot at the Euro 2016
tournament the value of the players on
the pitch will exceed four and a half
billion euros in financial terms Spain's
team is the most valuable Germany's
ranked second and Frances third the
euros most valuable player in monetary
terms is Cristiano Ronaldo he has an
estimated market value of 110 million
euros Germany's Thomas Miller ranks
third at 75 million euros
Ronaldo also earns the most 45 million
euros a year in salary and endorsements
in comparison women make far less former
German national team players say Lia
sausage earned just one hundred thousand
euros in 2015 Ronaldo's club is also
swimming in cash where Alma droid is
Europe's biggest money-making machine
followed by Barcelona Germany's richest
club Bayern Munich ranks fifth
but while most Spanish clubs have piled
up huge debts Bayern Munich is in the
black the Bundesliga champions earn most
of their revenue from ticket sales
sponsorship deals TV rights and sales a
fan memorabilia last year they raked in
twenty nine point three million euros
still German clubs receive less money
from sponsors German law forbids
commercial interests hermit aning a
controlling stake in teams here which
puts off Russian oligarchs and Arab oil
sheiks with deep pockets the football
business also has its downside the huge
sports betting industry attracts
criminals who win big using money
attained through illegal means sometimes
they even arrange to have matches fixed
but that doesn't stop folks from loving
the beautiful game for some soccer is
almost a religion and in it
Germany are world champions more people
follow big matches and go to church and
during the World Cup or European
Championships many drop everything
they're doing to watch the games
Germany's GDP Falls by as much as 0.4%
as a result but the tournaments also
mean people rush out to buy large screen
TVs be your sales also enjoy a boost and
will no doubt rise even more should
Germany become European champions